the Joe Rogan experience dude Fox News
is designed for old people it's on loop
and my tits on loop in the living room
so many old people when I go over their
house they're watching Fox Fox News
about Fox News white men over 60 is
mandatory at once Fox News and shake
their head I can't believe these libs
yeah I can't believe them it's C lock
her up lock alright why they tryin to
sneak in I don't believe them I don't
trust them they run out of so much
material sometimes when I come home to
my parents house and they've run out of
material to talk about on Fox News and
they start getting really having to pop
culture that's when it makes me laugh
when they stare like did you see what
ariana grande was doing the other day
I'm like they got nothing to talk about
they're just blood they're empty at some
point well it's linear guys like these
shows our opinion shows as much as they
are news shows they're mostly opinion
show yeah news is it part of it is
opinion yeah it's just such a weird time
man you know what's really interesting
to me too is like if a liberal goes on
Fox News they get a ton of [ __ ] oh yeah
any of the presidential candidates that
have been on Fox News like I think yang
I know Bernie's been on Fox News and I
think Tulsi has definitely been on Fox
News as well yeah and people just get
real mad at them yeah because it's just
there's this thing when over there yeah
talking to those propagandists it's just
it's like it's um it's like the way that
people talk about you is really funny
when they're like you know when they
label you with something and there's our
boy
whatever Oh Biden was there to look at
see I just wonder about his skin that
there pull what are they pulling it back
with fishing wire to keep it up up on
his head it just seems he seems oddly
stiff you know I'm saying yeah like it
seems like everything's pulled like this
is not a I expect a certain amount of
laxity in a man's face when he reaches a
certain age particularly around the
forehead area I'm just not seeing it I'm
not seeing any movement either which
makes me wonder about that like I want
to see expressions in your forehead my
worry is his lack he has a very big his
he lacks the ability to have
like a cohesive story like he's not good
at being like have you ever seen him
talking to kids by the pool it's the
weirdest [ __ ] talking about hairy
legs what the [ __ ] he's like it'll do a
bunch of little black kids he's like and
the black kids would come up and they'd
see my hair go up and bubbles come up
they touch my hairy legs what the [ __ ] I
just think his brain is he's losing a
lot of I tweeted something this morning
cuz there was someone put up a video of
models on a runway on a catwalk and
they're all tripping and falling at the
same spot these dumb shoes they're
wearing and I was like this is Biden's
brain cells it's like they think they're
on the right path until they get to this
spot they just can't [ __ ] did you see
the thing that he was talking about God
creating women or no and then he called
his wife his sister's you know the you
know I forget what it was I forget what
the gaff was but it was one of those we
list him like what your what do you say
like it's it's like he has no brakes but
his cars don't going down the hills my
god jeez I had a [ __ ] choice I hit
the wall [ __ ] I just can't remember the
word creator revert refers to God as the
thing hey actually I like that more
that's not on it you know what I think I
have a different take on it let's play
it cuz I want I wanna I have a different
take on because when I listen to I said
oh I know what he's doing which one do
you think it is first it was a bottom
one the second way he doesn't want to go
you know stop pause you can't be
President
oh stop pause pause listen we can't play
any games here folks this is a really
old man who can't talk like this is not
a joke like that right now you know the
thing play that again play that again
this should get you into a mental
hospital right they should be like hey
Joey you are right we all these truths
to be self-evident all men were created
by go you know the you know he had three
strokes while he was saying that the
first one what does that word
self-evident is that we hold these
truths to be self-evident but it didn't
sound right it'll hear it again doesn't
do it self Levin he's drunk
that dudes either drunk or you can't
talk we were just
real evident he shouldn't be doing this
in still evident and then he says when
he goes he could have just said all men
and women are created and he could have
just said equal and gotten out of there
and been like [ __ ] it blew up and
instead he goes bother you Martha give
me I think he didn't want to say the
Creator because there's a lot of people
religious thing yeah there's a lot of
people that would say well what are you
trying to say you believe in evolution
or not
are you a science deniers o Biden Joe
Biden's of science denier that's it but
that's part of the problem with all
these any my biggest beef with anybody
in the Democratic Party when you watch
these debates is they all want to say
the thing that they really feel but
they're tiptoeing cuz they're scared out
of their [ __ ] minds of someone going
up did you warn just sexy and she's not
she's anti-trans because she referred to
you know they did they're waiting for
them to [ __ ] up well they're making
people behave the way they would like
them to be hanging right there forcing
compliance right
[Applause]